let's talk about a story involving
WikiLeaks and Julian Assange on July 8th
just over a month ago
27 year-old Democratic staffer Seth rich
was murdered in Washington DC now it was
initially described as an attempted
robbery gone wrong but some disagree
with that because the killer or killers
left behind Rich's wallet his watch and
his phone and if the goal was to rob him
you would think that after killing him
they would have at least taken his stuff
although maybe not if they left in some
kind of panic uh Seth Rich's father said
to reporters if it was a robbery it
failed because he still has his watch
his money and his credit cards Julian
Assange did an interview yesterday with
Swedish television suggesting implying
that Seth rich was now I don't I want to
be careful here maybe a WikiLeaks
informant or the WikiLeaks informant
around the leak DNC emails not Russia I
will play the video for you and people
are coming away with basically one
impression which is honestly or
dishonestly because it's true or because
of some kind of message that Julian
Assange wants to put in the media
discussion he is implying that Seth rich
was WikiLeaks its source on the DNC
emails take a look Donald Trump has had
a disastrous few weeks if you look at
the polls he needs a miracle in the
American political lexicon there's such
a thing as the October Surprise the
stuff that you're sitting on is an
October Surprise in there we even know
what you're sitting on WikiLeaks never
sits on material whistleblowers go to
significant efforts to get US material
and often very significant risks as a 27
year old I works for the DNC who shot in
the back murdered just two weeks ago for
unknown reasons as he was walking down
the street in Washington so that was
that was just a robbery I believe wasn't
it
no it's there's no finding so that is
distorting what are you suggesting I am
suggesting that our sources
take risks and they are they become
concerned to see things occurring like
that but was he one of your sources then
I mean we don't comment on who our
sources are like the suggestion about a
young guy being shot in the streets of
Washington because that we have to
understand uh how high the stakes are in
the United States shortly after this
interview WikiLeaks announced that they
were offering a twenty thousand dollar
reward for information leading to a
conviction in the killing of seth rich
now there is a faction that believes
Julian Assange is knowingly or
unknowingly wittingly or unwittingly
being manipulated by Russia or maybe
even the Trump campaign to hurt Hillary
Clinton now one piece of evidence people
point to is that Roger stone this huge
Trump supporter recently claimed to be
in touch with Julian Assange just two
days ago speaking to the South West
Broward Republican organization Roger
stone said the following take a look to
the October Surprise which would be your
fourth test on that given what Julian
Assange has intimated going to do well
it could be any number of things I
actually have communicated with Assange
uh I believe the next tranches documents
pertain to the Clinton Foundation but
there's no telling what the October
Surprise may be
why on earth would Roger stone be in
touch with Julian Assange but stone is a
known liar and implying something you
know to be false is also a tactic to
create drama the other issue is Julian
Assange could be contradicting himself
because he has said many times Louis
that the WikiLeaks submission system is
by definition anonymous so that even
WikiLeaks themselves often have no way
of knowing who sent them information or
identifying where leaks came from uh III
honestly do not know what to think I am
presenting this at first it was just
conspiracy theories that Seth rich was
killed in some kind of cover-up
retribution or proactive killing to
prevent him from spilling the beans on
something he knew I didn't find it
worthwhile of coverage at that point now
that Julian Assange is saying this it
is the dynamic of the story drastically
uh I'm I'm kind of thinking that this is
not a connection he would draw if uh if
he didn't at least believe that there
was some connection there
even if he doesn't necessarily know
rights uh he doesn't seem like the type
of guy to just drop something like that
uh
and knowing that it's it's false or not
having any other information or just are
just throwing out there because it's
salacious uh uh but I could be wrong I
really don't know if he is indeed
throwing this out there to create drama
or because it is salacious or to get
attention which I I agree doesn't
particularly strike me like Julian
Assange is mo it would be hugely
irresponsible and unethical we will
follow this and we will see where it
Altima goes let's take a quick break
plenty more after this
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed dot-com slash TDP s I don't
really like going into glasses stores
and trying on glasses well the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker dot-com / TD
yes it costs nothing